what's like the wildest or most like
dangerous thing you've done on stage or
in life I'm kind of similar I love
skydiving I love crazy stuff and
swimming with dolphins or humpback
whales and Tonga has been incredible but
there is a lot of experience you know
Bear Grylls yeah yeah yeah so I went
with an adventure with him and we were
in Bulgaria and we went Skydive after we
were in the swimming to Glacier Lake
getting this helicopter we go up it was
like Derek all right that's what we're
gonna do we'll just jump out of this
helicopter and there's this guy with
this like black mask on and I get in
there strap in and we're like oh we
gotta jump out now now now and I'm
realizing that I don't have these straps
here oh no and and then I'm hanging out
the window and I'm like I'm not strapped
in I'm not shipping and he's like one
two oh my God okay now let's do it for
real let's get you strapped in I was
like
I I I thought it was the end of me
I I thought I was like this is it I'm
gonna die here we go I was not breathing
in that story and I didn't realize it
until the release um
wow what a way to mess with someone yeah
yeah he did that on purpose making it
like obviously I feel like he's done
that more than once
there might have been a little bit of
something coming in and out
for the glacier water change color
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]